boa tarde pessoal tudo bem este então
foi o tempo que rolou no cronômetro
é o tempo que eu preciso para participar
das paraolimpíadas de tóquio em 2020
deixei rodando pra você que não é um
minuto às vezes é pouquíssimo tempo né
então esse é o tempo que eu preciso
a participar da paraolimpíada de tóquio
em 2020 que é o meu grande sonho como
professor falou sobre esses cota tem 26
anos
sou funcionário e estudante da
universidade para atletas de natação
representa um clube de porto alegre e
agora vou contar um pouquinho mais para
vocês na minha vida que vem mudando de
nove anos até hoje
bom um metro de 2007/2008 participava em
uma escolinha de futebol
qual era o meu sonho de ser jogador de
futebol como entre outras pessoas
acredito que a maioria dos jovens têm um
sonho eo meu sonho era ser jogador de
futebol
representava esse clube ali está aqui
está a minha foto
isso foi um dos últimos jogos que eu
participei pela pela escolinha e depois
disso aí começou a mudar e vocês vão
acompanhar junto então em 28 de janeiro
de 2009
nesse local que vocês vão ver na foto
sofreu um acidente de moto onde um
caminhão cortou minha frente precisa
amputar uma perna esquerda
então depois desse dia aí começou a
nascer um novo maurício
após esse incidente após uma fatalidade
que às vezes o destino preserva coisas
pra gente a gente não não está adaptado
e precisa se readaptar à vida com esses
detalhes
nisso surgiu a natação na minha vida
depois de ter ingressado na faculdade
fiz a disciplina de natação e comecei a
participar após o término da disciplina
entre para um clube que comecei a
treinar e aqui foi a primeira competição
onde vocês podem ver que é a minha mãe e
o coordenador do nosso curso aqui de
educação física e aqui foi a primeira
competição que eu participei que foi
aqui em santa cruz do sul mesmo onde a
gente tira a dor numa academia e eu
comecei a gostar então esses treinos que
a gente estava realizando até então não
eram tão focados como a gente vai ver o
decorrer do tempo que foi aumentando né
aqui então a minha primeira competição
regional
em 2015 o ano de 2014
eu somente treino participei de nenhuma
competição porque ali eu começava a
criar um gosto por a natação que começou
a preencher esse vazio que faltava do
futebol como o futebol para mim era tudo
e eu tinha esse grande sonho de
participar de uma seleção brasileira
jogar um grande time
a anotação veio pra mostrar que eu
poderia participar e poderia chegar à
seleção através de uma outra forma
através de um outro esporte que poderia
me ajudar muito mais ainda que o futebol
então não não teve a sequência né
aí o decorrer do tempo com a faculdade e
tudo mais
as disciplinas que a viu eu encontrei o
basquete em cadeira de rodas também é
representante um time aqui de santa cruz
joguei alguns campeonatos fora do do
estado com outros times e desde então eu
precisei fazer escolhas né
entre a natação eo basquete hoje
totalmente focado para a natação
basquete e infelizmente tive que deixar
de lado mas é um esporte que eu gosto
muito também acompanha os meninos aqui
da cidade são dedicados 100% ao ao time
isso é uma coisa também que a gente
precisa cuidar é mazé eu quando
participa de alguma coisa a gente sempre
tem aquela vontade de ganhar ea minha
vontade é sempre de ganhar cada vez mais
é sempre chegar mais longe
eu acredito muito em mim e que eu posso
e mais longe do que eu tô ainda né
então eu precisei fazer escolhas deste
ano de 2018
o basquetebol natação
optei pela natação já estava dando
resultados atualmente o quinto no
ranking brasileiro na minha principal
prova que os 100 metros costas
treinando cada dia mais para conseguir
chegar entre estes chegará até o
primeiro lugar e consequentemente
conseguir uma vaga para a seleção
aqui também
entre os esportes entre a olimpíada do
rio 2016 que aconteceu eu tive a honra
de poder participar do revezamento da
tocha
eu trouxe junto aqui pra vocês lê onde
eu participei fui convocado e graças a
deus tive a felicidade de ser
presenteado com ela
então isso aí foi um momento muito
marcante para mim porque como eu estava
no meio da natação o índice papa para o
rio 2016 a gente sabia que era
impossível porque eu estava nadando com
o trabalhador fazia dois anos apenas e
mas eu estava tentando alcançar e assim
a gente foi treinando e aí quando surgiu
o a proposta de que até o revezamento da
tocha
logo não sem dúvida nenhuma assim me
inscrevi e fiquei na torcida
o chá é possível é capaz que vão chamar
maurício aqui do sul aqui de uma cidade
não tão grande porque a eu trabalho aqui
mas eu moro em candelária que aqui
pertinho impossível que vamos chamar é
mais vamos fazer a inscrição vamos ver o
que vai dar
e aí eu sempre conversando com os
colegas de trabalho um dia recebi um
e-mail a você foi convocado para o
revezamento da tocha meu deus é aquele
dia nem trabalhar mas consegui nem aí eu
fui lendo foi lendo no outro dia eu
recebi um e-mail que era uma errata
aquele meia que é isso né da alegria
para as pessoas agora tirar
aí eu fiquei acompanhando em seguida
acho que deu uns três quatro dias em
outro e mail de novo você foi convocado
por revezamento já não agora eu vou
ligar primeiro antes de comemorar
qualquer coisa para ter certeza entre em
contato com a organização e tudo mais
e disse olha recebi um e-mail há uns
dias atrás e aí uma errata que eu não
era um condutor mas agora veio o outro e
eu quero confirmar com vocês têm certeza
se eu sou um dos condutores ou não e aí
a moça disse olha vou te falando uns
pontos em 6 cm disse tem e eu fui lendo
para ela assim em cada vez estava certo
estava certo e aí foi indo foi indo e
até que chegou um ponto que ela tinha
precisa ter um logo da do rio 2016 no
cantinho assim eu testei e então agora
tu é um dos condutores da tocha
então pra mim foi muito grande foi uma
honra muito grande poder fazer uma
mínima participação no rio 2016 é eu
tinha o sonho de participar da
paraolimpíada
mas sabia que era quase impossível
porque dois anos na natação
vamos dizer que é muito pouco meus
colegas de natação a gente nunca se
tratam como adversário um outro porque o
nosso adversário é o tempo é o tempo que
eu mostrei pra vocês que eu preciso
bater não é ou não é o meu colega que eu
preciso vencer
op que a gente sempre quer uma medalha
tudo mais mas abriga o principal ponto é
bater o relógio bateu o tempo para
conseguir fazer parte
nessa correria da de vai para o
revezamento não vai quando recebi o
oficial
faltava meio dia para entregar os
documentos que valia pra fazer parte
meu deus aquele dia foi uma correria e
aí precisava mandar por correio e tudo
mais e eu não sabia mais onde e quando
eu olhei assim eu fui entregar um papel
que precisa ser assinada
aí o moço obviamente bem assim a esse
documento vai dar 80 reais
uma folha temos tudo isso uma coleção
soft só mandar só se ele assim não é
arte não pode encaminhar porque isso pra
mim foi uma realização muito grande ter
conduzido a tocha esse registro ser
presenteado com com a tocha olímpica
pra mim é uma satisfação muito grande é
um dos sonhos que eu venho realizando
quando eu escrevi era um grande sonho
também hoje em dia eu tenho esse sonho é
participar de tóquio em 2020
que sanções que a gente precisa colocar
e tem em nada disso é fácil
na verdade é muito difícil às vezes a
gente recebe cobranças que é preciso
encarar outro não consegue realizar uma
coisa bem feita até a semana passada
estava numa competição não foi o
resultado que eu esperava mas a gente
precisa erguer a cabeça treinar até o
ano de 2019 agora que vai ser muito
importante que já vai ter avaliações vai
ter já provas referente a toque 2020 que
é aonde eu vou me focar mais
então essa daqui também 2016 teve essa
honra de poder conduzir a tocha fazer
parte dessa rio 2016 que pretendo agora
em 2020 está na paraolimpíada aqui então
é mais um registro da natação esse foi o
início do ano de 2018
aonde eu nadei a fase regional foi
primeiro colocado nos 100 costas segundo
nos 100 livre e terceiro nos 200 metros
onde eu tive hoje eu fui premiado com o
melhor atleta da competição o melhor
índice técnico da competição que pra mim
foi muito bom porque a gente nadou no
nosso clube é o de mostrar o trabalho
que a gente vem fazendo diariamente chão
é seis vezes por semana treinamento na
piscina mais cinco vezes na academia e
às vezes a gente ouvir algumas coisas e
recebe algumas críticas mas ninguém sabe
o que um atleta passa por fora disso
está ali com a medalha e troféu é muito
bonito mas a gente vem num por trás das
câmeras 11 assim por coisas que a gente
tem que levar todo dia eu infelizmente
não consigo ainda ser somente um atleta
profissional
eu trabalho estudo e treino os meus
colegas têm a maioria só fazem só
treinam são pagos pra nadar mas eu
infelizmente ainda não tô correndo atrás
não vou desistir
não vai ser fácil chegar aonde todo
mundo deseja não óbvio que não pôde se
fosse fácil eu fui para uma
paraolimpíada todo mundo estaria se
fosse fácil eu conseguir alguma coisa
todo mundo teria as pessoas
querem mas não tem a vontade de ir atrás
e eu depois que eu me acidentei hoje faz
nove anos que eu me acidentei eu corro
atrás dos meus sonhos não deixe nenhum
minuto passar eu tenho dedicação 100% às
vezes me cobro demais até mas eu preciso
porque eu quero chegar a um lugar que se
eu não tiver essa cobrança não vou
conseguir chegar lá eu sempre comento
quando converso com amigos que eu me
senti que não tinha 17 anos e eu
maurício de 17 anos e maurício de 9 anos
hoje em dia eu não troco minha vida de
nove anos que eu tenho agora por dia 17
óbvio a sofrer um acidente e um dia
perde tudo mais mas o aprendizado que eu
tenho e as conquistas que eu venho
realizando ea minha cabeça que eu tenho
hoje em dia para pensar nas coisas é
muito diferente
eu nunca imaginei participando tentando
alcançar uma seleção há por exemplo se
não fosse o futebol quando me sentei eu
achei que estava tudo perdido não ia ter
mais nada que eu vou fazer agora não tem
uma perna e eu vou fazer mas bem pelo
contrário
conheci muitas pessoas conheciam estou
conhecendo muitos lugares e tô vendo que
não ter uma perna não é impossível a
gente precisa colocar metas e colocar
argumentos da vida assim que tu vai do
quieto vai atrás e aqui esse ano já
iniciou muito bem não foi muito boa
competição do último ano mas a gente
trabalhou eu sei que eu venho me
dedicando que o próximo ano vai ser
melhor ainda que o próximo ano vai
chegar mais perto de si um minuto 5 e se
deus quiser em 2020 vocês vão me ver lá
porque eu tenho esse desejo eu tenho
essa vontade eu vou conseguir
às vezes a gente precisa colocar e sei
que vai conseguir não há será que vai
dar certo não é será vai dar certo
será que é dar certo maurício sem uma
perna agora com 17 anos no auge da
adolescência deu certo
no meu pensamento foi até melhor do que
eu imaginava está sendo melhor do que eu
pensava que a ce se eu tivesse as duas
pernas
então eu luto diariamente por isso é
cansativo dia é mas eu acorda todo dia
com
vontade de viver aquele dia mais um
pouco porque a gente nunca sabe o após
eu por exemplo sair para trabalhar
quando me acidentei e eu acordei dois
dias e meio depois no hospital sem uma
parte de mim então acredito que a gente
deve ver cada dia se dedicar a cada dia
mais a o que deseja
aqui estão alguns registros que eu
participei de uma das fotos uma colega
que ela fez um trabalho de pós ela está
entre nós aqui
aqui é outra foto que eu gosto muito e é
um pouco antes a gente no treinamento
que realiza aqui na piscina da
universidade mesmo essa imagem eu gosto
muito porque é uma deficiência que hoje
em dia eu sei lidar muito bem e eu estou
conseguindo conquistar coisas com
deficiência
não foi o fim foi apenas uma etapa que
eu tive que passar e hoje eu tô sabendo
lidar muito com isso aqui é mais um
registro isso é uma ótima competição em
são paulo pensando um pouquinho né se
deu tudo certo não é mais um registro
mais uma foto em aqui foi uma competição
em bauru são paulo onde eu nadei seis
provas
aqui a gente colocou fez uma foto assim
eu consegui nadar seis provas e eu tive
primeiro lugar em todas as provas com os
tempos melhores do que eu tinha que foi
muito bom para nós a gente estava com
expectativa boa e ea equipe em si
conseguiu ter ótimos resultados
pra mim é muito bom é que nem o
competente é muito bom a gente ganha uma
medalha mas o mais importante às vezes
pra nós no mundo do esporte no alto
rendimento na natação
às vezes a medalha não veio mas o teu
tempo queria alcançou é melhor ainda
mais prazeroso
então é óbvio que a gente sempre quer
ganhar medalha a gente sempre está em
primeiro e como eu sempre quero eu tenho
muito espírito esportivo às vezes não dá
certo eu me cobro muito mas é preciso
parar e pensar que no erro que aconteceu
eu vou treinar em cima dele para o
próximo ano não acontecer de novo né
e aqui foi onde eu tive
a primeira experiência na seleção
universitária brasileira né
foi o primeiro fiz a meca games que teve
agora nesse ano 2018 que foi o
parapanamericano universitário onde o
professor comentou que eu consegui me
consagrar campeão pan americano nos 100
metros livre que foi uma das medalhas
que eu consegui nada de mais duas provas
onde obteve o segundo lugar
mas como eu falei o que o segundo lugar
com os tempos melhores que eu tinha
então é uma honra muito grande
representar o nosso país sempre né ea
primeira convocação a gente nunca
esquece
pra mim foi uma satisfação muito grande
participar desse campeonato
agora a gente está treinando da semana
que vem já viagem para outro campeonato
representando o rio grande do sul
o único para atleta do sul sou eu que
vou ir nadar junto com o pessoal do
político é que a gente costuma dizer
e pra mim é uma honra muito grande eu
representei o brasil já foi a seleção
universitária mas foi assim eu fui o
nosso país eu a gente que faz
treinamento de alto rendimento a gente
vive com dor e eu ouvi uma vez uma coisa
de uma pessoa que ela teve assim um
vencedor já tem a dor então pode ser um
vencedor vai ver com dor que às vezes a
gente acha que está tudo acabado mas não
é apenas o início e hoje em dia eu penso
diferente hoje em dia eu vejo que tem
muita coisa que eu devo fazer se deus
quiser
como eu falei mais uma vez quero toque
2020 e muito obrigado a todos pela
atenção
espero que tenha levado alguma uma boa
impressão que tenham a conseguido colher
alguma coisa de boa pra vocês e se deus
quiser a gente vê por aí se vê em top
2020 e muito obrigado a todos pela taça
[Aplausos]